oh yes Sarah it is
[Music]
love my mother
hate my brother
so let's get after it and have a spot
a little [__] bread
um well where's the bird where's the
bird Chris ah well Chris did another
walket talk we didn't we got another
walk and talk from the chomo project
Widow walking around pontification he
left the stickers on his hat he left the
stickers on his hat I do these from time
to time
he's probably gonna put it back in a box
and sell it that's right yeah regularly
scheduled but I don't get
to walk enough to
do them because you're like also you're
not a [__] free agent anymore you
work for spectrum news or something the
news news Nation Nation yes so you're
not free agent anymore that doesn't even
make sense dumb [__] take your stupid
fake out of so as with many things in
life it's a sticker that says remember
hat goes on head
you have to wind up just
taking the opportunity I'm telling you
he's going to resell that hat not only
is going to resell the hat but look at
his hoodie it's missing the drawstring
which he pulled out in a fit of rage
because it went through the other side
it's like [__] it I don't even need it
yeah I do the same thing though to be
honest
when it comes schedules routines
are very difficult but very helpful
so
I want to take this on that theme
there's a theme to his walk today
hopefully it's another dead animal to
where to begin
to where to begin the Chris Cuomo story
it to begin to where to begin the Chris
Cuomo story
and here is you know as far back as I
can remember I always want to be a free
agent
that's fall back exactly remember I
always wanted to be a pontificating
douchebag
what I have gleaned from most writing
most stuff that's his word of a day
calendar we kept talking about it
remember the
most different versions of things that
I've come across
anywhere you just picked up another bird
he just picked up another bird
look
[Laughter]
Chris Chris what's happening come on man
Chris Chris you've got to stop this is a
sick [__] thing he's doing here we go
most different versions of things that
I've come across hey look another bird
in the same area don't break the bird's
neck right where I'm leaving all the
birds
bird serial killer
where would I leave all the bird poison
these birds keep dying I don't know
Chris I'm uh you know bird murderer and
I'm a host of the chomo project
these birds they keep dying on this
chalk x with the Acme poison
ing anywhere in chat said he's a
murderer
is the answer
if you have a goal in mind an objective
like for example I want to kill 15 Birds
this week that's my goal I have my own
goals
the place to start
is anywhere
and with anything
because
we are almost hardwired
to resist change why change is hard
and comfortable or forced on you because
you helped your brother
that's all he did I know out of
everything he did remember we we
defended him like it was super weird to
defend and be like
all he kind of did was stand up for his
brother though
I mean wouldn't you
would like the familiar we see it in
everything
all appetites
all predilections
all Tendencies wow he's he's just
throwing what he's trying to sound so
much smarter than he is it's the best
all he does he really fancies himself
with thinking man
this is not true of all people right
very few things
are true all the time for everybody and
what are you saying Chris I'm gonna
speed up to when you kill another bird
hold on because
energy has to go somewhere what I hate
him are you talking about so much I hate
him so much you know I was meditating I
was meditating uh in my Dojo next to my
soul crystal
and I came to realizations of the world
and you do have the choice of what to do
with it
comfortable uncomfortable I for example
take uh above the illegal dose of trt
that's what I do that's that's me though
we're all different I for one can slip a
hundred dollar bill with my doctor and I
get a boost yeah not many people get
prescribed Deca because it's only for
horses but I get it yeah cause I'm built
like a horse
my doctor said I'm healthy as a horse I
said good then give me Deca give me Deca
I want to get as big and some Trend too
I want to get [__] huge I'm gonna
make all those [__] a CNN look when
they see me at the bodies
he said I was healthy as a horse which
means I got a big dick that's all he
cares about because it's Italian of
course and my pressure
permanent impermanent
very often it's just a step
very few problems have Simple Solutions
well no you were a problem at CNN in CNN
and there was a simple solution to fire
you very simple well that was easy and
that's okay
so when you're having whatever your
crisis is and avoid
what I was often instructed to do
um by the people who raised me
which is well were to fight him just
immediately punch him in the [__]
nose you know this kid made fun of my
Mars gravy when I was a kid I swear to
God I put his head in the toilet he
could have died he still has brain
damage that [__] slammed the seat down
too I almost broke his [__] head open
he's in a wheelchair now unrelated but
I'm a different guy now look around you
look how much worse something could be
sure you didn't get yeah like at one
point you had a job at CNN
and now you're going for a walk killing
birds
things really get out of control real
quick for y'all Chris
chat cpt's writing your monologues
that's dude the fact that he was so
close does that sound like me yes
get out of here get that raise
sure you didn't get that position that
job sure sure you got five cause you to
fed your brother sure whatever
she he they
left you damn whatever all these [__]
weirdos
foreign
look I'll be honest with you I don't
mind doing the Lefty stuff but too much
too much fact stuff going on over CNN
I'll be honest with you you know like
I'll support them but like you know in
their own house I don't want to see you
kissing in public
this relationship that's what a
progressive meatball Italian would be
like how Progressive bro just kissing
your home if I see you kissing a punk
I'm bashing the facts head in that's
what's happening
sure whatever it is
went horribly a lot it could be so much
worse
you could be spending 15 on HGH and as a
shortage because that's related to eggs
you know that
I don't you know I got money you know
I'm doing all right I'm all right but
I'm just saying you know my neighbors
you know I can't imagine how you don't
get through a day without eating six
dozen eggs I drink them raw like Rocky
yeah my Italian hero Rocky Balboa that's
how I get all my vitamins
I
you know it could be worse you could be
eating a Sunday gravy not made by your
known that's why he's killing birds so
he can steal their eggs and eat them
on that level of analysis of course what
level of analysis we've been watching
for like 10 minutes you haven't said
anything
it's good
to have a sense
of relativity
but it reminds me Albert Einstein
you ever heard of this guy
Jew real smart
at the same time I want to see the iron
Sheikh now yeah brilliant smart Jew man
personal huh
all pain
is personal
did you hear how the deep thought you
guys didn't hear that deep thought oh
I'll be personal all pain is personal I
mean unless you're you know trapped in
an elevator burning to death with other
people I guess I guess that's how the
person sort of maybe shared pain but
like if we were trapped like a great
white concert like let's say you were uh
you know in 9 11 which we will never
forget
my good friend Seafood was a firefighter
that day
of course what bothers you we know Chris
[Laughter]
what is real to you
is real for you Chris looks like
somebody who says 911 changed this
country way too many times like just too
many times he says it we know so
you know the idea that oh well
so many have it harder than I do okay
true real
but but what about those folks who got
it better than me huh who the for the
[__] they get off who the [__] do they
think they are you understand that I'm
just making good money but I couldn't
get the Raptor with a leather package I
got had the F-150 Raptor with the suede
seats you know what kind of [__] club
I look like now yeah you don't have to
[__] you know how long the waiting
list was for another one
you better bring a [__] Army pal
talking to Zucker you two [__]
you
what if I want to go to CNN and get a
food court and get a sandwich that I
like what am I online you want a
sandwich I get you're on the list you're
up there with Andrew Cuomo now
you better bring an army a [__]
lawyers pal
what does that mean
about how you have it
and why is it that pervert oh Plato's
punk in the chat says and this is the
911 because you know this in the word of
Pete Davidson's father help it burns ah
he says
holy [__]
whoo sorry
personally
given that notion of relativism
you're still talking about
we often find people
who are absolutely in extreme
circumstances
a disease Beyond cure what does this
shirt say this should say captain Chris
no
this is the chomo project free agent
have but please don't
Captain Chris
disease Beyond cure and Captain Chris
will make you bored tonight
horrible
War
and difficult Captain Chris will murder
Birds tonight
he he is he is and then cook them in his
mama's gravy
[__] [__]